I'm right now I'll be talking about
applications of convex optimization
okay so I'm going to be talking about
you know Nina's given most of the
introductory material for what I did you
do when I sort of introduce convex
optimization is slightly different light
particularly talking about applications
I mean why do you want to do in the
first place and of course it's fun math
but but sometimes there are other
reasons for doing things which I don't
always see but you know that's what of
you might have that but basically way to
think of convex optimization these days
is it's really like an extension of
linear programming so linear program
became sort of to the forefront in the
50s and 60s and it you know opened up
because people could solve with simplex
method and then other methods to solve
larger problems suddenly applications
for it just became enormous well convex
optimization is sort of in that stage
now and so the number of applications
people are being able to do because of
the applicability of efficient solvers
are just sort of blowing up so that's
kind of the theme for the presentation
I'm going to show a very tiny subset of
examples but hopefully that will give
you some of the flavor of the breadth of
what you might possibly be able to do
okay so let's talk about optimization in
general I mean optimization is sort of
throughout science we need to define
things that are optimal or find the best
solution or something like that and
typically mathematical optimization
there's there's three different
categorizations whether a problem is
linear or nonlinear okay the next one is
whether a problem is constraint or
unconstrained okay and the third one is
whether your optimum your finding is a
local optimum so this is the landscape
bumpy and I find a little pit here or is
this the the best possible often out of
all possibilities okay so now when we
think about convex optimization I'm
going to recategorize things so this is
sort of a new new paradigm shift instead
of thinking linear and nonlinear we now
think of convex and general nonlinear
problems because linear programming is
actually just a subset of convex
optimization okay
and we can think of constraint
unconstrained and local global but for
convex optimization the latter two
categories are pretty much irrelevant
because for any convex optimization
problem if your function is convex you
can
transform it into a form like this we're
objective is linear okay so any convex
problem is actually a constrained
problem in effect and if it's not
constrained it's going to be unbounded
in solution so there's kind of no point
in doing it anyway so so so that one and
the other big thing is that a local
optimum is always a global optimum for a
completely convex problem so you don't
have to worry about searching all the
mumps and valleys convexity guarantees
it and again Nina showed convexity think
of you know convexity is like if I have
a set I can connect two points without
going through the edges of the set
that's that's convex and a convex
function as a function like x squared
and any two points in the graph above
the graph of the function you can
connect so that's that's the essence but
we always typically transform convex
functions as an objective into a linear
function so we're always talking about
convex sets okay
and here's a bit about why it's become
main story I've already mentioned that
it's the good-good solvers okay but they
can reliably solve problems so I mean
typically if you see a linear
programming problem you go oh that's I
know I can solve that I can call SEAPLEX
or blah blah blah and it's it's done
right well the convex overs are not
quite there but they're pretty darn
close so you get a convex problem boom
you can solve it you know it's a solved
problem now general nonlinear solvers no
way okay maybe you'll get a solution
maybe you won't maybe we'll work for an
minimize you know wait for a week and
see if it gets anywhere but these are
pretty certain things and that's why
it's such a big thing there's some other
key points okay I'm emphasizing this the
optimum is global so you know you have
the best solutions well those problems
are solved okay conic problems have a
dual problem and I'll show an example in
my examples of using the duality theory
may give sensitivity and other things
and also this I think is actually a
really important one most non-linear
solvers require smoothness to get
derivatives to be effective
well convex did those cones Nina showed
you they weren't smooth they had corners
okay and that's very typical in the
convex and the convex
don't care about those corners just like
a linear programming thing you have a
polygon the the optimum is always at a
corner so you need those corners okay so
those are I think really important so
I'm gonna here the applications and I'm
gonna go through a lot of these fairly
quickly I hope I get to them all but so
there's an in finance data fitting
signal processing image processing
geometry and graph theory and that's
only just a subset of the fields that
convex optimization is being used for
okay and I'm going to shows an examples
I hope will be illustrative of how you
do modeling but also the breadth of
applications okay so let's start with
finance okay I want to make some money
so we sort of generated a really
artificial possible portfolio of stocks
so and the mean return these stocks is
white 20 which is not very realistic but
okay we're playing math here so it's
okay but the concept and then we kind of
covariance matrices I'm just showing the
diagonals of the covariance matrices to
give you an idea of how risky like this
is a wicked risky sock you know this one
is pretty safe okay so what we want to
do is we want to balance the return we
want to get it we return
but balance that with the risk because
of course you get the best return by
taking the you know the this this one
stock which has the highest return but
that may have a bigger variance than
you're willing to accept in terms of
risk so let's look for a balance okay so
we're going to do is we're going to say
find a weight vector so we're gonna wait
each of these six socks with W 1 W 2 so
on and so forth and those have to add up
to 1 to make you know our our entire
portfolio and our return is going to be
the the means that miu column dotted
with the W vector so it's going to be
the sum of the you know the mean of the
returns and the risk is going to be
determined by this covariance matrix
which I've just shown you the diagonal
so but it's actually a whole matrix so
this is actually a quadratic this is a
quadratic objective we're trying to
solve for is what are the weights I
to do okay and we're gonna set up a risk
aversion parameter I'm not you know my
financial advisor tells me I'm pretty
pretty risk tolerant but other people I
know are very risk-averse they don't
wanna take any risk so there's there's
always a you know depending on the
person you are there's really so this
alpha sort of tunes that that risk
tolerance and again if we had real stock
data and stuff we'd be able to tune that
more to the market but that would be too
complicated for this this presentation
so again we have weight constraints
we're gonna we we want the weights we
can't buy a negative amount of a givens
equity so W has to be good and no this
is this vector greater than or equal to
zero so each component has to be greater
than zero plus the total has to be I
mean our entire portfolio the weights
have to add up to 1 so those are our
constraints so all we have to do is
suppose I fit in with alpha equals 1 so
my risk tolerance parameter is 1 I can
do this and I should have been entering
these things as I went along
I was too busy blabbing and sorry about
that
ok quadratic optimization and oh I
forgot to that I farted I've got to do
this thank you para Tosh now hopefully
this will work there we go okay so now I
have weight so basically this tells me
that I want to pick the last four stocks
and I want to ignore those first two and
if you look at the you'll take a quick
look at the portfolio sure enough those
are the ones with the lower return lower
returns and they have comparable risks
okay or I could be more risk-averse say
my risk tolerance just PI then you get a
different different way weighting of
weighting of stocks and you actually buy
a little bit of those those less return
ones too to balance the the overall risk
okay now here's a plot I can I can
quadratic optimization as you notice
it's quite fast so I can actually solve
hundreds of problems here I'm doing one
thousand six hundred and sixty three
different realizations of possible
weight vectors okay
and I do that and I can compare so this
these are the these are the random
realizations down here okay and this is
my this is my front found by convex
optimization so it always maximizes the
return for a given amount of risk so
that's a that's sort of a classic and
there's all sorts of finance problems
you can do that get more sophisticated
and the real way to do is to sort of
estimate the covariance properly for the
stocks and Michael could probably help
me with that but again we're keeping
these okay so another whole set of
applications that this is kind of one of
my favorite ones because I always like
approximately things and fitting things
is data fitting okay
so we're going to explore all sorts of
different data fitting problems and how
we can do it so so let's just let's
consider fitting a cubic polynomial for
equally spaced points okay so a cubic
polynomial can be given by this basis
okay I've got I'm just taking a small
set of points so you'll be able to see
not because the solvers can't handle it
but because I want to keep the problem
so so you can kind of see what's
happening okay and then Mathematica is
this beautiful function that's been
there for version one called fit that
just boom and this just uses linear
algebra to find the fit okay but it
actually is that linear algebra is
solving a minimization problem it's
finding the least squares deviations
okay and I can I can show this plot okay
and you'll notice that these points so
that's that's my favourites I chose the
points perfectly so the fit wouldn't be
that great okay now another way I'm
going to show you how the linear algebra
works because that sort of leads us up
to how to model the convex optimization
problem okay so we've got a matrix a
this is called the design matrix
basically I'm just taking the the basis
functions x minus 3 to the minus 3 and
minus 2 so on and so forth that makes
the so-called devote design matrix and
then the land in your algebra problem is
just least squares of a comma Y ok
and let's see yep okay and that gives me
exactly if you look that gives me
exactly the same coefficients I've got
with fit and that's actually how it
works if it makes this design matrix
from your basis it solves these squares
boom it's done okay but can we do more
well with convex optimization we can so
one thing that the the least squares has
is it's quite sensitive to outliers so
if you have a whole bunch of points
which fit along a curve and a couple
points which way out there
those two external points tend to pull
the curve away from the proper fit and
and do that because the penalty of
square is quite strong as they get large
so another way to do it is to do what's
called l1 fitting okay and that's
actually just a linear optimization
problem now the I could actually solve
the l2 problem by using norm of plus
with norm two norm now why am i using
this inactive of plus okay this is this
is one of the the flies in the ointment
of our modeling that we're still trying
to figure out how to do the reason is
because Y is a vector so and and this is
symbolic so this would our list of if I
just had plus it would thread over that
and it would give something the wrong
dimensionality I want it I want to have
this not threaded until a dot C is kind
of computed so that's why I have that in
active plus okay and you'll probably see
a few of those okay so I can plot the L
to fit in the l1 fit and as you see the
l1 fit actually goes it's sort of in
this case it thinks these two points are
the outliers okay and it's quite close
to the other points okay that's a that's
a property on one fit well we don't have
to with convex optimization we don't
have to stop there I mean that that we
could have done in the 60s with when
your linear program right but let's do
something you will do LP fitting I mean
if we can do a one Norman to two warm
why can't we do a P norm
well we can so we can so here and notice
how fast that was so I fit a whole bunch
of different norms 11.5 to 3 okay all
using the same conic optimization
problem okay it's done
it's done the transformation of cones as
Nina in for all those problems in the
instant I push the button so that's how
fast these solvers are okay and again
you can see the the range from you know
here's the the 11.52 and you get to
eventually get to the infinity or the
max norm and you get more sensitivity
outliers there so that's a I think
that's just sort of an interesting thing
so you can expand your horizons from
just a few things to a whole bunch of
things okay now let's do a different
kind of fitting and this is called
cardinality constraints in E so suppose
suppose I say have these four basis
functions 1x x squared X cubed suppose I
say I want to fit only uses two of those
functions okay
and so the cardinality the base is the
number of nonzero components I'm using
out of the basis this is another way of
and sometimes people called out the l0
norm and paratah should be talking more
detail about some of these methods let's
let's change this back to two I change
this Fri so if I do it aloud okay so
there's a trick here so again I've used
this in active plus I'm using quadratic
optimization because this is a quadratic
I could use conic optimization and use
that transformation to a linear
objective I show is just convenient
conic quadratic optimization okay so
here's a trick so I'm going to have I'm
going to set up in addition to my
coefficient vector C I'm going to set up
a W vector which are integers and these
are going to be binary they're going to
be either 0 or 1 since they're integers
and it's constrained means you don't
want it has to be either 0 or 1 okay
and then I I let the number of nonzero
ones be the total I'm allowing and
here's the trick I find a bound that's
as big as any possible coefficients I
think I'm gonna get ok and then by
bounding this this is a trick to get a
linear constraint instead of a non
linear constraint out of that and this
is very common in in mixed mixed
programming ok so I do that and I get a
weight vector so this says if I'm going
to do this I'm going to use only the
first and the third coefficients and of
course those are the even coefficients
in that distribution
points I had was kind of like a
quadratic so an even function is gonna
obviously fit it fit it best okay and
then we can show those fits versus that
and it's quite you know it's quite quite
similar so it's not much worse if I only
use two basis elements well now there's
a this is a really the reason I'm
showing this problem is well first I
think it's kind of neat but it also
shows a principle that's often used in
convex optimization which is the idea of
relaxation so you have a problem now
that mixed integer problem is solvable
the solvers did it for a small size but
if I started to do a big example boom
you're gonna be waiting a long time even
with even with efficiency because the
branch-and-bound stuff takes a long time
okay so the idea is well can we solve a
problem that's nearby that will kind of
get to the same solution so can we relax
the original problem look at the
solution decide whether it's adequate or
not and go with that and the answer in
this case is yes we can do a relaxed
problem so there's something called and
there's fit regularized fits and that's
you know been a common thing in
statistics and stuff so we're going to
use the same norm the same to norm but
here I'm going to add a parameter lambda
times the one norm of just the
coefficients so the idea is I want to
limit so so I want to balance between
having the least squares fit be as close
as possible but I also want to keep the
coefficients small okay so so what is
what does that do
okay well let's let's look at the fit
that actually gets me okay so we can
find it for say a particular value of
lambda and notice I'm just getting a fit
vector now so I'm not actually writing
out times the whole basis I can do that
for so so it turns out that if this
lambda gets big enough to keep this norm
small it's going to be zeroing and this
one is getting close to zero right so if
I go a bit farther it actually can zero
out some of these coefficients so what
I'll do is and this is you
some sparse array tricks but I'm gonna
threshold because remember that that
optimization has a tolerance so it might
not be exactly zero so we'll threshold
under the tolerance to get zeros and
they use sparse array and count the
number of nonzero values in a sparse
array too and here I can do a plot as a
function of land of the number of
non-zeros that we get as a function of
lambda okay so here for the smaller
lambdas like I showed you you get four
eventually we get to that problem we saw
before where we get two Lambs now the
question is and it can actually be
proven I'm not gonna do it but any of
these any of these solutions with the
two basis functions use exactly the same
basis functions as that cardinality
constraint
so the relaxed problem so basically with
this relaxed problem I found want to
instead of solving the whole mixed
integer problem I say okay well I'll do
this l1 regularization get the number of
zeros I want boom I'm done okay so so
that's the that's the idea okay so now
let's look at a big problem we can do
with this sort of thing and this is
called basis pursuit so suppose I have a
huge basis of thousands of functions is
often called the dictionary okay and I
want to find a relatively few number of
basis functions so I can get a good
approximate function out of that whole
thing now here's an example with Gabor
functions okay and I'm not gonna
actually run this because I've pre
computed this the Gabor functions sort
of look like this and these are six
different examples of them they shift
the centers shift along this axis and
then the frequency shifts as well okay
I'm going to I'm going to set up a
dictionary of a bunch of these which so
I'm going to subdivide the temporal
space I'll subbed by a frequency so in a
store floor so you got a whole bunch of
basis I make a design matrix using our
design matrix which is sort of a
companion thing to fit okay and oh dear
I think I'm going to erase the examples
here and this is well actually I think
this will work so I'll try and I'll try
and actually run this
okay so this okay now the key thing
about the length of the basis is it's a
30,000 element basis
okay now any useful function model is
not going to have 30,000 basis elements
okay that's not gonna be useful if I do
a least squares fit so I can get the
design matrix for that that's a pretty
big nature this is a 500 by 30,000 so if
I actually run least squares with this
matrix it's going to take a long time
because that's a big matrix okay it has
to do a an SVD on this matrix I'm going
to reduce the basis matrix size a bit by
threshold again because those Gabor
functions drop off quickly so I'll do
those out to get a more sparse thing now
let's consider a signal okay so here's a
signal this comes from Boyd Boyd's book
on convex optimization
okay we'll discretize that by
discretizing over my time intervals and
now we can do an l1 fit you notice that
takes a little while and here I'm using
fit so we've actually directly put
regularization into fit so you don't
actually have to go through the convex
optimization functions you can just do
it with fit okay and that's document and
notice this returns a sparse array it
tells me I found with with lambda equals
1 I found 53 basis elements so I've
reduced that 30,000 to 53 now how good
is that okay well there's one more thing
you have to do the regularization is
that that optimum I found is for the
balance and once I once I've chosen the
basis elements I actually want the L to
fit just using those basis elements and
so that's what these extra steps are for
so let's compare the signal and our
approximation okay and it's pretty good
in fact on this plot they're both pod
and you can't tell the difference this
is actually the difference and the error
is fairly small so instead of 30,000
elements I've gone to 53 which I think
is a significant okay so I've got to
keep moving I'm gonna skip this total
variation regulation because I want to
get to the next one and I'm speaking too
long because I want to get to this this
image which I this one which I really
like okay so the idea here is we want to
reconstruct it
a corrupted image okay so here what I've
done is I've taken an image and I've
sort of so we have positions where the
pixels are known to be correct in other
positions where the pixels are not known
to be correct and you want to sort of in
paint between the correct pixels to
guess what the best one ones are okay so
here's my corrupted image okay the
convex optimization walkway and want to
do is I want to minimize sort of the
local variation from one pixel to the
next okay and I take the two norms of
all those the sum over this so it's a
it's a quote in in the image size it's a
quadratic number of terms in this sum
and these each actually each are modern
by these second-order cones he was
talking about and then I have I require
that it equal to my data at the known
positions so that's it I can actually do
this within minimize directly but
there's still some processing issues I'm
working through so it takes a bit longer
so what I'll do is I'll write out the
norm constraints okay those are the so
I'm going to convert this to a linear
objective with that transformation I
showed before so a bunch of those here
are my equality constraints oh maybe I
didn't enter the oh I didn't oh yeah I
don't want to run this anyway I don't
want to run this anyway cuz that's the
absolute timing so this image which is
not huge it takes 74 seconds to do which
is quite a beaut you know but it's it's
quite a few it's it's 500 by 500
essentially so you're talking about
twenty-five thousand pixels to work out
so some of 25,000 so let's look at the
actual results okay that's my
reconstructed image okay which i think
is appropriate for today's topic and i
just closed the wrong thing let me open
this this is the original image and you
can hardly tell the difference okay so
it's actually from that corruptive thing
you couldn't even read the big cone now
you can read it again so it's a it's a
it's an image treatment okay so geometry
I'm going to yep so I'm at a time so I'm
going to skip geometry but Nina showed a
couple examples there
and yep so and then the last one which
I'll just go through quickly is because
it uses the dual is the the max cut
problem so so the idea and I'll go like
a minute or so so that's all be very
schematic on this the max cut problem is
how do you divide a graph so that the
vertices that divide it have maximum
weights and it's an NP NP complete
problem ok so again we're using this
theme to solve this we're going to use
convex optimization we're going to solve
a relaxed problem instead so we can
actually write the problem out and I'm
not going to go through all the math but
we it depends on the laplacian matrix of
the graph and now right and then you can
actually write an exact function that
doesn't miss this can take forever for
big big problems so we'll set up ISA by
so and basically what we eventually get
in terms of this is we get our problem
we want to maximize the trace of this
well if you look at the page for semi
definite operation this is exactly what
the dual problem looks like so instead
of remodeling we'll say is okay we'll
give semi definite an optimization these
matrices and we'll just get to do a
solution out and that will give me the
solution for my max cut problem turns
out you have to do a bit more you have
to process the matrix you get out that
semi positive definite matrices to see
if it satisfies the conditions but we
can do that and now we can actually test
it on a real graph so here's a Peterson
graph and we can find oh dear me not
quite sure why that didn't work but it
should should show it should show the
actual so it's not
not quite sure why oh did the space come
in yeah thanks
that so that right so okay thank you
thank you that's I must have put that in
yes there it works okay so and in that
solved almost instantly whereas the
exact problem would we'd still be
waiting till past past my my questions
okay so quick summary I've shown a few
applications there are many more have a
lot of these applications I showed were
taken from our reference pages for the
various solvers and we'll be adding any
more examples as we go so that's a quick
quick overview of convex applications